um I knew he died
what context please what like did we
just get clicked clickbait I nearly died
on my way to the airport okay so I was
filming um
a video right so I had I was filming a
video that day before we got the flights
we got a flight at midnight yeah so we
rocked up at like 6 a.m and then had the
wedding at 10 A.M it was yeah it was
like we we packed this in oh yeah yeah
and uh well you packed it in yeah it's
really me and everyone was kind of like
I guess I'll just joined kind of on his
flight yeah we all went on the same
flight yeah
um yeah so I was um I was doing a video
shoot in uh in gunma and uh dude man it
was oh boy it was like cursed from the
start so I've I you know I rent cars in
Japan fairly often I've rented a car in
Japan from this one location at least 10
plus times I've been there so many
goddamn times and I you know I just know
who you are now I've been there so many
times right so when you book a car in
Japan if it's winter season you probably
want to just get snow tires just in case
because you don't you don't know where
you're going right and I always I always
get snow ties always and so I guess no
ties
a rock up to the rental car place and
it's 8 A.M and we're gonna get going
because like our video we're on like a
tight schedule we gotta get to the next
place it's about two hour driveway and
uh as we're in Japan one question
they'll ask you when you rent a car is
normally they'll ask you where are you
going and it's normally a chill thing
they normally kind of don't care it's
not like American Tears yeah it's yeah
it's not they like sometimes they
they'll they'll be a bit persistent
about it but sometimes they'll be like
where you going you're like author but
cool
all right okay and so I showed him where
I was going and he was like and then he
started talking with the other staff I
was like what the [__] was when a lot of
good move yes what's up
um and then he he pulls out the
Translating thing and he goes basically
just saying you can't take this car and
I was like what do you mean I can't take
the car he's like it doesn't have snow
tires on it you didn't have snow ties I
was like I [__] what do you mean I
asked for snow ties I got the receipt
right here yeah he's like no no there's
no snow Ties on it so uh and I just got
like a normal ass small car I thought
okay [__] well with no snow tires well I
I I clicked snow tires right so I was
like what the [__] and he said you can't
take this car okay so what we can do is
if you come back in an hour we'll get
you this car and he points at this card
I look down I'm like yeah that's it they
said it eight seater I don't need an
agency that's massive I do not want to
take this so we're going down like small
roads
and he's like oh I mean we can't do
anything we can't we can't let you have
the cars right what I was like fine I'll
take the eight seat of them like what
can I do right I've got to go
and it was double the price yeah and I
had to pay for it even though I wasn't
my [__] fault so like we walk out and
as we're walking out the guy starts
running
all right what's up he's like oh yeah
there was no tires on the car
I was like what
so I just lied to you he lied he I think
they [__] up and they misread there
was no ties on the [__] car this
whole time right and I'm like oh my God
okay fine all right so we go back in oh
my good at least I can get the car and
they do something they've never done
before they've they asked me for like my
passport and stuff which they never
asked me for okay because I I you know
you live in Japan and it's given the
zaidu card right yeah well so normally
even with that right if you have a
Japanese driving license which I do they
normally don't need anything else yeah
um and if you're a resident in Japan
even if you go to hotels if I'm correct
you have to look at this I don't know to
my knowledge if you are a resident in
Japan they shouldn't be asking you for
like passport or zaru card even when you
check into a hotel I always do yeah
because if you're a Japanese person I
never get asked yeah right right and
they're not supposed to ask you but they
do for you when you're a foreigner even
if you live in Japan I don't know why
it's kind of kind of annoying but it is
what it is and same with rental cars if
you have a Japanese driving license they
shouldn't require anything else because
if you live in Japan that's probably
your ID anyway yeah right so the dude
started asking me for my passport and I
was like bro I'm not what the [__] I've
literally rented cars I live here like
10 times and you've never asked me for
this [__] what the [__] he's like whoa
did you have like a value yeah fine just
dude come on what the [__] yeah suddenly
I get it it's whatever we're going
and then we're driving and there's no
snow anywhere in gunma there's no snow
at all I'm like well this is it was
[__] waste of time and then we're
staying in a ryokan for the night and I
see where the ryokan is and it's like
there's all these roads around and
there's this big black empty area and
it's just a mountain and our ryokan is
right in the middle on top of this
mountain right I'm like how bad can it
be so we start we start driving and as
we start making our way up this mountain
it's 50 minutes from the bottom of the
mountain to the top of the real castle
geez wow and there's a giant frozen lake
at the top right and so we're driving
and the snow starts to get like bigger
and bigger and bigger and 10 minutes
into driving this and it's it's
literally like Initial D like the like
the roads just like this yeah going up
it's like if you if you're drifting it'd
be Heaven yeah you're just drifting the
whole thing right and as we're 10
minutes into this drive there is a car
that is sideways in the road that is
skid out and spun out right and I'm like
oh okay okay guys don't worry I'm a good
driver I'm good I'm good and there's
just cows with me and the cameraman okay
that's fine it's fine we'll be fine
we're going up down is the scary part so
we're going up and it's all kind of it's
a little dicey like you can feel the car
is kind of like skidding a tiny bit here
and there and you're like okay come on
come on Carl you got this we get up and
it's fine but I'm worried about the next
day so I'm like we gotta go we're gonna
go back down yeah and it's snowing yeah
overnight yeah so I was like oh yeah
and the car she's like can you can you
back the car up a little bit more in the
parking lot and I'm trying to back it up
and the car just can't move it's like
stuck yeah because there's just so much
snow I'm like I'm like assume I said uh
it won't it won't go it's not happening
she's like yeah fine get out yeah so
next day we do film all the stuff and
we're ready to go
and we go down and we start driving and
I noticed that like I'm like hey guys uh
don't wanna don't avoid you anything but
uh we can't stop the car the car cannot
break so so we literally have to just go
down this without fully coming trying to
control
so we can break right because you know
your brakes in the Cobble stop yeah but
it won't slow down Beyond like 20 or 30
kilometers an hour yeah Jesus so you're
pretty much stuck at that and if you try
to stop the Cobble skit app right
because it doesn't want to right because
the car doesn't want to do it [__]
else so I'm like well don't worry guys
30 is a really reasonable speed and
we'll be fine and there's some turns
where the car you can feel it start to
go like this just sliding you're like no
guys don't other guys I've drifted
before
I was like is what we find I know how to
turn into the drift this is fine I know
what I'm doing I didn't really know what
I was doing but I was like yeah it's
fine it's fine we'll just we'll go slow
we'll just pump the brakes every now and
then just slow it down don't don't try
and harshly break and then we there was
this car in front of us at one point I
don't know how this car was there yeah
and we're going down this pretty steep
hill and I noticed the car is just like
stopping and I'm like uh okay and so I'm
trying to slow down and I'm like how the
[__] has he stopped I can't stop like I
literally cannot stop the car right and
I'm just getting slowly closer to this
car and I'm like well [__] we're like 30
meters away from this car and I I'm like
what the [__] do I do because I'm
thinking in my head I'm like man I can't
stop the car pretty sure if I slam the
handbrake that's gonna make it worse
yeah
um so I look if there's any other cars
coming and I I'm like all right well
let's go in the other side of the road
because I I know the choice I couldn't
stop and I want to hit this guy yeah so
I turn on the other side of the road the
car is like uh I don't like that but we
managed to keep it safe we'd steer in
and we'd steer back in it was all chill
but it [__] helps terrifying geez the
dude just stopped in the middle of the
road I don't know why
it's a straight road she was putting you
to the test yeah yeah oh you can drift
can you fortunate and another car came
at the same time it's like oh I have to
hit something yeah like what do I what
do I hit like so you're driving in
winter is scary be very careful Jesus
but luckily we made it down no problem
was totally chill good stuff that's
pretty why they wanted my ID I think I
think they were like this this
motherfucker's gonna crash this car
where is this where is this guy going
yeah why are these snow tires Jesus
surprise it was kind of crazy that's
terrifying yeah but luckily it all
turned out okay uh I think we're pretty
I'm pretty good Under Pressure I think I
don't freak out so I'm pretty good at
trying to manage the situation but it
was too scary still especially when
there's other people in the car like if
I question it's me I'm like this [__]
is fully all insured as long as I'm good
we're going like 10 miles an hour I'm
like we'll be fine yeah if I don't want
to scare them
I gotta drive again he's just like I can
drift guys and they're all just like
we're gonna die
like other than that Carl was like your
driving is a fantastic car like thank
you can we just don't talk about the ice
section let's talk about the snow areas
yeah so be careful if you drive in Japan
really make sure you look where you're
going because no ties are good but they
can't do everything yeah I genuinely
think that that road was just like you
needed chains to like oh yeah I was
gonna say like did they not give you
change no that you can't you couldn't
rent them and I wouldn't even know how
to put them on I've never put chains on
my car
you've come a month in advance
oh my God these these [__]
didn't even know you needed snow tires
when you come in so you know what makes
you think they're gonna have change yeah
I I it was it was luckily the snow was
light enough where the snow tires were
fine but if it had snowed anymore I
think it would have just would just have
been like sorry we can't go up there
yeah it's just too it's too bad jeez
yeah you couldn't stop it's scary it's
pretty [__] yeah because I mean like
I I went up to go see my grandma
um you know up in Sendai for foreign
can get some snowfall but like the the
zowel like mountain range stops a lot of
the snow right yeah like it's a lot
though so like so when I saw that there
was like a good 30 40 centimeters on the
road I was like this is unprecedented
like it must be this winter has been
absolutely [__] for Japan right now
amazing for the ski Fields but I'm not
going to the ski Fields this season
because it's just full of Australians
yeah it's also no offense Australians
it's also crazy how you you're going so
careful on this road and then of course
the public bus driver will be like
[__] multi-track drifting going down
like it like it is sleeping I'm like
this is [__] up how does he drive a
bus and he's taking this like it's easy
he's like he's like one hamburger like
doing gachapels when I like full-on
steering man it's [__] up I I was
terrified for my life and this bus came
downhill look dude didn't look phased
yeah he was like he was like yeah
whatever ice clothes dog I've been doing
this my whole life